[Musik]
Abteilung halt
ungerade aus
Federzug Rhodos schütteln es ist die
Vorbereitung auf einen feierlichen
Moment Mitte Mai 2023
die neuen heimatschutzrekruten in Berlin
werden gleich ihr Gelöbnis ablegen
vorne Augen rechts die kommt hier rein
wo wir jetzt rein marschieren das ist
der lange Stock schwarz rot gold
30 junge Menschen haben sich hier in
Berlin freiwillig verpflichtet für
mindestens sieben Monate warum
ausgerechnet jetzt angesichts des
Ukraine Kriegs und was halten die
deutschen von ihren Militär
drei Rekruten in Berlin waren bereit
sich für diesen Film begleiten zu lassen
zufällig sind sie eine Männer ihre
Nachnamen sollen im Fernsehen nicht
genannt werden
einer von ihnen ist Toni aus Chemnitz er
hat Umwelttechnik studiert dann kam die
corona-pandemie zu Hause im Homeoffice
sozusagen habe ich gemerkt dass ich eine
sehr schlechte Selbstdisziplin habe und
da dachte ich mir kann die Bundeswehr
vielleicht ein bisschen mit dem
militärischen strukturellen mit ein
bisschen nachhelfen und der zweite Grund
war dass ich mir große Sorgen um
Klimawandel mache und da sich der
Heimatschutz auch auf Naturkatastrophen
fokussiert sah ich das als Möglichkeit
mich da auch ein bisschen drauf
vorzubereiten
Kevin aus Saarbrücken hat vor einem Jahr
Abitur gemacht
bei dem Überfall auf die Ukraine letztes
Jahr habe ich mir auch gedacht was wenn
es wirklich hier bei uns haben
einfach nicht haben und möchte im Ernst
verteidigen können
aus Berlin frisch von der Schule war
halt in der zehnten Klasse wusste noch
nicht wo ich ungefähr hingehen möchte
dann hat mein Vater zu mir gesagt pass
mal auf und jetzt sag mal Spaß damals
Spaß gemacht also guck sie mal an
sprechen sie mir zum feierlichen
Gelöbnis nach ich gelobe
Herr Bundesrepublik Deutschland
das Gelöbnis auf die Truppenfahne betont
Treue zu einem Land das mit seinem
Militär hadert wie kaum ein zweites
zweimal haben deutsche Soldaten die Welt
überfallen das halt nach bis heute
die daraus hervorgegangenen Hemmungen
die fehlen halt den meisten anderen
Ländern
da gibt es halt dieses Zögern diese
Bedenken nicht in dem Maße
wer Pflicht Armee im Westen wer Pflicht
Armee im Osten Auftrag gegenseitige
Abschreckung
mit dem Mauerfall fällt auch der Druck
die russische Armee zieht ab der kalte
kriegsschein vorbei wozu also noch
Militär
bundeswehrkasernen werden geschlossen
Einsparungen vorgenommen das alles war
die Folge einer durchaus realistischen
Wahrnehmung die Helmut Kohl ja in die
Formel gebracht hat wir sind von
Freunden umzingelt und eben nicht von
Feinden wie das frühere deutsche
Vorstellungen waren
die Haltung der Deutschen zu ihrer Armee
freundliches Desinteresse
das verstärkt sich noch als die
Regierung im Jahr 2011 die Wehrpflicht
aussetzt und ankündigt dass die
Bundeswehr kleiner werden wird sie wird
allerdings auch besser werden doch es
wird nicht besser
veraltete Hubschrauber fehlende
Flugzeuge störanfällige Panzer Symbole
für eine vernachlässigte Truppe und nun
[Musik]
nach dem Überfall Putins auf die Ukraine
ordnet Kanzler Scholz ein Sondervermögen
an 100 Milliarden Euro extra für die
Bundeswehr dazu noch 2% des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes jedes Jahr wir
müssen deutlich mehr investieren in die
Sicherheit unseres Landes um auf diese
Weise unsere Freiheit und unsere
Demokratie zu schützen wir müssen uns
wieder mit dem Gedanken beschäftigen
dass wir uns verteidigen können müssen
und dass wir das auch jedem potenziellen
Angreifer signalisieren wir schrecken
dich ab dadurch dass wir uns verteidigen
können aber auch bereit sind es zu tun
wenn es darauf ankommt das ist ein
Paradigmenwechsel in den Köpfen der
jetzt nötig ist nach 30 Jahren
was heißt das alles für die Soldaten
in der Berliner Kaserne steht
marschieren auf dem Programm
geschlossenen Formation
der erste Kontakt zu Waffen kommt erst
noch zunächst geht es um Grundlagen
der freiwillige Wehrdienst im
Heimatschutz soll Nachwuchs anlocken
sieben Monate Einblick wie es zugeht bei
Militär Zug
und hacken auseinander
im Gleichschritt aus der soll 1400 Euro
netto im Monat trotzdem melden sich
nicht genug Freiwillige seitdem die
Wehrpflicht ausgesetzt ist fehlt auch
ein Draht in die Gesellschaft
[Musik]
warum nicht gleich so
Gleichschritt Arsch
das Gespräch über die Auseinandersetzung
der Sicherheitspolitik ob ich diene ob
ich nicht diene ob ich Ersatzdienst
mache aber welchen Dienst ich dem
Gemeinwesen tue ist uns etwas verlustig
gegangen und das wieder an den normalen
Familientisch zu kriegen das wäre glaube
ich schön und das tut uns auch
Gemeinwesen auch gut die Deutschen und
das dienen das Verhältnis ist ambivalent
für diesen Film haben wir repräsentativ
gefragt wenn jemand zur Bundeswehr geht
finden das demnach 82% der deutschen gut
10% nicht aber das eigene Leben
einzusetzen um die Heimat zu verteidigen
dazu ist nur knapp jeder zweite Deutsche
bereit
kommt jetzt die Zeit der Dankbarkeit der
Anerkennung
viele Soldaten hoffen es
ich wünsche mir auf jeden Fall mehr
Wertschätzung dass man auch auf der
Straße einfach mal angesprochen wird
tagsoldat danke für den Dienst dass das
würde für mich das würde mein Herz zu
nah werden welchen Ruf glaubst du hat
die Bundeswehr momentan nur vorher
kriegt man aus dem Medien vor allem mit
was alles schief läuft sage ich jetzt
mal gerade im Beschaffungswesen dass man
trotzdem
großzügigen Militärbudget oder einem was
halbwegs gut ist im Vergleich zu anderen
Ländern doch nicht ganz so gut
aufgestellt ist
sowas halt und ansonsten doch auch
wieder in positiveres Bild seit dem
Ukraine Krieg weil man sich dann doch
der Notwendigkeit von dem Militär auch
wieder mehr bewusst geworden ist
[Applaus]
doch nicht alle haben ein neues
positives Bild der Bundeswehr Berlin
Anfang April 2023
friedensaktive unterwegs beim
Ostermarsch eine Jahrzehnte alte
Tradition mit Jahrzehnte alten Slogans
Höhepunkt der Friedensbewegung war
Anfang der 80er Jahre als Zehntausende
gegen die Aufrüstung der NATO
demonstrierten
damals mittendrin ein jung-sozialist
namens Olaf Scholz es geht darum dass
wir einen Aktionskonzept für einen
friedensherz entwickeln eine Ikone der
friedensbewegten
ex-spd-kanzler und
Friedensnobelpreisträger Willy Brandt
seine Worte für viele eine Richtschnur
wir müssen der Gewalt und der Androhung
von Gewalt im Verkehr der Staaten
entsagen
endgültig und ohne Ausnahme eine
ausgewogene truppenreduktion kann den
Weg dahin Ebenen
Abrüstung Gewaltverzicht lange
gesellschaftlicher Konsens Anfang der
2000er nutzt das ein SPD-Kanzler sagt
Nein zum Irakkrieg für Abenteuer stehen
wir nicht zur Verfügung und sichert auch
damit seine Wiederwahl
jetzt mit Putins Überfall auf die
Ukraine hat sich der öffentliche Wind
gedreht auch das linke Lager ist sich
uneins also ich merke schon dass ich zum
ersten Mal das Gefühl habe dass
eigentlich meine Position wirklich nicht
mehr Mainstream ist obwohl ich also
natürlich habe ich nie vorher jetzt die
absolute mainstream-position gehabt aber
ich hatte eigentlich nicht das Gefühl
dass ich in der gleichen Art und Weise
an Ecke von daher gibt es natürlich auch
eine ziemliche Spaltung innerhalb der
Linken also eher
waffenlieferungsbefürworter dann aber
auch Leute die Ahnen oder Angst haben
dass man in einem dritten Weltkrieg
hineinschlittert Frieden schaffen ohne
Waffen hat die Parole ausgedient der
Historiker Herr friedmünkler glaubt ja
viel zu lange habe sich Deutschland
vorgemacht das Wirtschaftskraft
ausreichend als friedensfaktor
[Musik]
bis hin zu der Vorstellung Militär sei
sozusagen eine auslaufgröße
der russische Angriff hat sichtbar
gemacht dass das nicht funktioniert das
meine eigene Einstellung mein eigener
Friedenswille ziemlich uninteressant ist
solange es Leute gibt die denken ja dass
die anderen ruhig friedlich sein umso
mehr kann ich meine expansiven oder auch
räuberischen Ziele durchsetzen darüber
ist in der Friedensbewegung nicht viel
nachgedacht worden müssen wir also
wieder mehr in kriegskategorien denken
auch Peter Brand ist Historiker und der
Sohn von Willy Brandt
er warnt vor einer Eskalationsspirale
das klingt sehr naiv Frieden schaffen
ohne Waffen aber
die gegenteilige Behauptung stimmt erst
recht nicht also Aufrüstung nicht
bereitet den
Krieg vor wenn du den Frieden willst das
hat auch eine eigentümerik das ganze ist
höchst riskant solange wir
in einer hochgerüsteten insbesondere
atomar hochgerichteten Welt leben in
dieser Situation bekommt die Bundeswehr
also mindestens 100 Milliarden Euro mehr
und eine Mehrheit der Deutschen ist
damit einverstanden
59% der Befragten befürworten mehr Geld
für die Bundeswehr selbst wenn dafür in
anderen Bereichen gespart werden müsste
34% wollen weniger Geld fürs Militär 7
Prozent nichts ändern wir müssen
Infrastruktur investieren wir müssen
eine erneuerbare Energien investieren
wir sollten endlich mal Geld haben für
eine Kindergrundsicherung damit es keine
Kinder mehr in Armut in Deutschland gibt
das sind alles Dinge für die dringend
Geld benötigt wird und ich meine dass es
da viel sinnvolle aufge hoben ist ich
würde auch lieber die Milliarden die
viel Milliarden für andere Dinge
ausgeben als für Waffen aber das ist ja
nichts was wir uns aussuchen an in dem
Fall unsere Sicherheit ist existenziell
ohne Sicherheit brauchen wir uns um
soziale Fragen keine Gedanken mehr zu
machen
[Applaus]
ein Truppenübungsplatz bei Berlin die
Heimatschutz Rekruten beobachten ein
Manöver
die Bundeswehr will ihren Neulingen
zeigen was Sie im Zweifel lernen sollen
simuliert wird das Verhalten bei einem
Angriff
[Applaus]
der Feind trägt rote Armbinden und kommt
aus Richtung Osten
das ist gerade passiert
die beiden TPZ wurden vernichtet eine
Gruppe hat es überlegt ob diesen TPZ zum
ersten Mal in ihrer Ausbildung geht es
konkret um Waffen zum Beispiel um ein
Scharfschützengewehr wir wollen halt
immer den ersten Treffer setzen und wir
versuchen ja auch immer sozusagen
höherwertiges Personal auszuschalten die
Neulinge des Berliner Heimatschutzes
wissen noch nicht wie Ihr Auftrag einmal
genau lauten wird klar ist im Zweifel
gehört auch töten zum Soldaten Handwerk
schon ziemlich krasses Gefühl auch
ziemlich auch beängstigend weil man ja
weiß wie viel Kraft auch dahinter ist
der Feind oder ich
Kriegslogik für die einen unerträglich
für die anderen unenttrennbar so sieht
es auch Kevin aus Saarbrücken
kann
man ist entweder in der einen auf der
einen Seite oder auf der anderen Seite
es kann mich treffen
in dem Fall wenn ein anderer
Scharfschütze mich sieht dann bin ich
das ziehen
[Musik]
ein Gespräch über Krieg und Frieden
manchmal kommen Soldaten dazu auch in
die Schule wie hier im thüringischen
Tonner also ich weiß nicht kommt ruhig
nach vorne kommt ruhig nach vorne
ja vielleicht die hinteren Reihen kommt
ruhig nach vorne da muss ich nicht so
laut schreien ja
Erik Günther ist einer der
Jugendoffiziere der Bundeswehr
hey ich möchte den Dialog mit euch und
wir müssen uns nicht anbrüllen
Schulen können ihn einladen zu Vorträgen
über Sicherheitspolitik und den Auftrag
der Bundeswehr ich möchte mal vorab die
Frage in den Raum stellen ob und
inwiefern ein Bundeswehrsoldaten der
Ukraine eingesetzt werden könnte ist es
aus eurer Sicht möglich ja oder nein
es geht nicht um Nachwuchsgewinnung
darauf legt die Bundeswehr wert
viele dieser zehnklässler haben vorher
noch nie mit einem Soldaten gesprochen
erlebt ich stelle regelmäßig fest dass
wir Jugendoffiziere um von uns zu
sprechen diejenigen sind die dann das
erste Mal mit den jungen Menschen in
Kontakt treten und seit Ausfall oder
Aussetzen der Wehrpflicht bleiben wir
auch für lange Zeit das einzige Mal wo
der Kontakt mit der Bundeswehr
stattgefunden hat
auch deshalb diskutiert die Politik über
eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht wahlweise
in der Armee oder im sozialen Bereich
für eine solche Pflicht sind knapp drei
Viertel der repräsentativ Befragten
25% dagegen eingeschlossen wohlgemerkt
die Älteren die nicht direkt betroffen
wären
auch der Minister hegt Sympathien die
Aussetzung der werfen war aus meiner
festen Überzeugung ein Fehler aber einer
den man eben auch nicht jetzt einfach so
korrigieren kann denn das kostet
wahnsinnig viel Zeit und Geld das wieder
neu aufzusetzen und wir haben gerade
andere Baustellen als die
jüngeren haben wenig Lust auf einen
Pflichtdienst schon gar nicht auf den
mit einer Waffe
angenommen jetzt wurde großer Krieg
entstehen ich könnte mir nicht
vorstellen jetzt da für irgendwelche ich
sag's mal alten Leute dahin zu gehen
mein Leben zu lassen weil die wenn die
Konflikte da starten nicht ein dafür zu
sterben man darf es heute nicht mehr
viel sagen ohne dann irgendwas zu sein
aber tatsächlich gibt es Punkte wo ich
sage ich bin stolz auf mein Land und
würde das auch offen so ausleben und im
Notfall eben auch dafür mein Leben geben
da kann man halt mit Familie finde ich
nicht so das Match nicht so und ja dann
ist auch immer die Gefahr ob man
vielleicht sage ich mal dort stirbt wenn
man in den Einsatz muss und das würde
ich auch meiner Familie nicht so gut
also nicht so zu ich habe keine andere
Leute einfach nicht weh tun das geht
einfach nicht
schießen
das Problem
Toni aus Chemnitz hat sich für sieben
Monate bei der Bundeswehr verpflichtet
er wollte mehr lernen über
Katastrophenschutz jetzt hält er zum
ersten Mal ein G36 in der Hand
Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen auch er
macht sich darüber Gedanken ich sehe
mich dem Gedanken gar nicht mal so fremd
ich glaube aber der Pazifismus ist auch
irgendwo zum gewissen Grad naiv zu
glauben dass eine friedliche Welt
einfach so daher kommt
und von daher glaube ich müssen wir
andere Wege finden um dieses die
Probleme die wir in der Welt haben die
zu Konflikten führen und irgendwo auch
systemisch hast
wie viel Militär verträgt unser System
die Frage wird dringender
denke das ist wichtig ist sich für
zivile Lösungen einzusetzen und die
Bundeswehr ist ein Militär und Waffen
töten
[Musik]
klar man kommt auch dazu dass man halt
die ein oder andere Person halt leider
erledigen muss aber ich Verteidiger
dadurch auch mein Land ich sehe das
militärische Lösungen Krieg als Mittel
der Politik dass das falsche Wege sind
ich glaube das muss das Ziel sein dass
es irgendwann keine Verteidigungsarmee
mehr braucht ich wünsche dass das
nachhaltig ist was wir jetzt gerade
erleben und nicht jetzt gerade ein Thema
von Legislatur zu Legislaturperiode wird
das wäre mir wichtig was ich mir von der
Zivilbevölkerung auch Wünsche ist mehr
Akzeptanz das heißt dass man nicht den
mit dem Bild herkommt
wir sind Mörder im Ernstfall sind wir
für die Person
wir beschützen sie von ihrem Leben
so drei vier Deutschland muss neuen
Nachdenken über den Frieden und den
Krieg
nur abwarten und Zuschauen geht nicht
mehr
so
drei vier